we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day here's a voicemail i
received i just wanted to let you know
about trump all right university
attendance you are aware that is uncle
who he was praising on one of his little
speeches not too long ago more the
professor at university attend so for me
that put everything together because I
really do believe his learning
disability I really do believe that also
those these emotional things and being
thrown away into a military school early
on for his behaviors which he also self
disclosed has a great deal to do with
all of this okay so this is in reference
to the whole can donald trump barely
read story that we did and some people
have been writing in saying david if
chrome can't read how did he get through
wharton what the caller is asserting is
that his uncle teaches at wharton so
maybe he didn't really have to do
anything to graduate the truth though is
that his uncle actually it was an MIT
professor but the main point which is
that maybe because of privilege trump
was able to sail through wharton without
really being competent that is
absolutely plausible and trump would
always tell the fact that his uncle was
an MIT professor as evidenced that he
himself was smart right we take a bit of
a jump i'll say i have uncles who have
done well i don't need to talk about my
uncle's but let me just say what my
uncle's have done is in no way positive
or negatively impacting what i would be
capable of doing the sins of the uncle
are in no way the sins of the nephew
right exactly on the bonus show today a
Ku Klux Klan leader has been murdered by
his own family mental health
professionals are increasingly warning
that the President may be incapable of
being President of the United States and
also a really funny tweet that is just
so dishonest and misleading about the
resignation of national security adviser
Michael Flynn will deal with all of
those stories and more on today's bonus
show get instant access to the bonus
show by signing up at david pakman.com
slash membership monthly and yearly
plans available discounts
available with coupon code I voted 17
check it out we will talk to you on the
bonus show